[Música]
bom pode ser que essas três palavras não
signifiquem muito prováveis
mas elas mudaram minha vida nos últimos
tempos e o conto porque a minha história
na verdade começa com uma história de
muitas outras pessoas um publicitário
extremamente insatisfeito com a
profissão que resultou na tudo pra fazer
uma mudança drástica na vida eu mal
sabia onde eu ia chegar antes mesmo da
propaganda dessa importância tão grande
na minha vida a ponto de decidir minha
carreira eu sempre fui uma pessoa ligada
às artes e eu considerei como uma opção
esse contato diário com as artes ele
sempre teve que acontecer
ah eu vou os espetáculos e assistir um
filme ler um livro e foi numa dessas que
há uns oito anos em são paulo assim que
eu me mudei para a cidade
aí foi uma exposição de arte popular
brasileira e confesso que saí de lá com
uma pulga atrás da orelha é uma grande
mistura diz de acabamentos de formas de
cores e técnicas e aquilo me deixou sapo
muito muito tempo e eles me perguntam o
que é a arte popular brasileira ela é um
complexo de símbolos de identidade que o
povo cria e preserva tem muito da
tradição do cotidiano das crenças e um
sentimento grande de coletividade e eu
saí de lá comecei a pesquisar e
descobrir quem eram os principais
artistas a que eu poderia te repente uma
outra visitar e as coisas foram se
desenrolando até que um belo dia do dia
pra noite eu decidir eu tava pra fazer a
minha primeira viagem a campo para
conhecer um artista popular
era uma quinta feira para semana o
telefone liguei na louca carlos e
marquei para o dia seguinte
na sexta feira depois de ter trabalhado
o dia todo as oito da noite saí de são
paulo em direção direção ao fim
vale do jequitinhonha que fica em minas
gerais é é tão norte de minas que já
fica quase ali perto da bahia
eu fui de encontro a uma ceramista
reconhecida mundialmente pela sua
capacidade criativa o nome dela é nimes
batista do santos ano jequitinhonha
vale lembrar que por muito tempo
estiveram o nome à de vale da miséria
isso por conta das baixinhas simas
níveis de desenvolvimento do lugar em
alguns lugares pouco se tem além do
bairro a dona heloísa e recebe na sua
casa muito simples e já oferece um café
pedindo desculpas por não ter muito mais
do que isso pra oferecer isso foi o que
houve onde reside até hoje eu devo ter
ido à casa da dona mesmas 20 outras
vezes e tem uma coisa sobre a vida dela
que eu queria dividir com vocês
hanói mesa através do barro ela consegue
retratar coisas que são parte do
cotidiano dela sendo aquela ver
acontecendo no dia a dia como é o caso
do caçador e deve escolher a que eu
considero peças que celebram alguma
coisa
no fim das contas ela retrata comigo
então uma celebração de ter comida nesse
dia e também ela faz essas peças são
extremamente delicadas e cheias de
detalhes acho que isso já diferencia
contrasta com a figura da namisa vocês
acabaram de ver ela também faz cenas
muito felizes como o sanfoneiro fazendo
música não só isso ela parte para o
mundo que eu considero mundo dos sonhos
que é todo ritual do casamento então a
noiva se preparando com a madrinha da
noiva eo noivo eles indo pra igreja e
tem um livro resumidamente disse que
nenhum homem até hoje se interessou por
minimiza o que eu acho complicadíssimo
de se publicar eu resolvi então
investigar
perguntei pela mesa mas por que a
senhora acha que nunca
sul e ela olhando no fundo dos meus
olhos disse que para casar
é preciso sorte que juízo e juízo eu
tenho não é mesmo
aquilo é o tipo de conhecimento que não
é pro nosso bico eu resolvi então
investigar essa relação dela com o
casamento mal sabia ela que tinha levado
o vestido que tinha sido da minha avó de
casamento para ela ver aquilo a
transbordou ela ficou muito feliz e um
pouco impaciente ficou observando aquele
vestido quando sem pedir o vestiu uma
das cenas mais lindas que eu tenho na
minha cabeça até hoje sempre vou lembrar
depois muito tímida ela me perguntou e
contou na verdade que tinha um sonho e
esse sonho era descer enterrada de noiva
o que eu entendo disso é que a menina
tinha um único limão na vida chamado
barro e ela espremeu para fazer a mais
linda das moradas
quando ela me pede mas enterrada de
noivo que ela conseguiu transformar esse
sonho em realidade
quando a enterrada de noiva essa
realidade de eternidade
essa história foi decisiva para que eu
entendesse e deixar as casas populares
de fato entrar na minha vida e até hoje
não tive arrependimentos
ah eu comecei a ter um conflito muito
grande com a propaganda nesse tempo eu
trabalhava na agência e eu me sentia no
fundo do poço porque eu estava fazendo
uma coisa que não necessariamente estava
me alimentando de uma forma como
imaginei que fosse alimentar e quando
chegava em casa no apartamento minúsculo
e eu olhava para aquelas quase 800 peças
que o trouxe de todas essas viagens que
cruzava o brasil eu entendia que ele era
o melhor lugar que eu queria estar
e foi assim a numa época que eu estava
literalmente no fundo do poço é meus
relacionamentos não estavam dando certo
tendo crise com amigos mesma família
estava completamente a tendo outros
conflitos
e eu entendi nesse momento depois de
muito muito pensar que quando a gente
está no fundo do poço
a gente aprende a construir a vida
usando somente o que é necessário
e esses caras me ensinaram muito disso
foi assim que eu comecei a atender o que
é que eu queria fazer
e numa maravilhosa noite de janeiro que
eu sempre vou lembrar eu tava quase
prestes a dormir quando de repente entra
uma idéia fechada na minha cabeça eu
finalmente entendi o que é que eu queria
fazer da minha vida que eu queria fazer
a entrar em um carro e sair pelo brasil
pesquisando os artistas populares suas
obras e sua vida aquela ideia era tão
simples quanto complicado e eu comecei a
pensar mas peraí como é que eu vou fazer
com que carro é esse
com que dinheiro ou alugar esse carro
como é que vou fazer um apartamento como
é que o conto isso pra minha família e
ali eu entendi que era de fato uma
história muito complicada sabe aquela
decisão que você não pensa duas vezes eu
pensei
fui lá e fiz foi assim que surgir novas
para nós uma busca por artistas
populares brasileiros e eu entendi
também que tinha um problema de pesquisa
poucos pesquisadores em doha campo então
eu também iria atrás de novos artistas
não só aqueles que eu já conhecia
foi assim que eu rodei 27 mil
quilômetros mas é 16 estados mais o
distrito federal é passei por todas as
macrorregiões brasileiras
meu único compromisso que eu fiz comigo
mesmo era de contar pelo menos uma
história podia de algum artista popular
nas plataformas do projeto
foi assim que eu consegui em quase 200
dias contar mais de 300 histórias seja
passou de uma até por dia o que houve na
verdade não só se resume aos artistas é
muito da cultura popular eu ouvi lo
apitadores de pedra pen ceder os
curandeiros parteiros vaqueiros uma
comunidade quilombola o próprio dialeto
artistas de um circo de decadente uma
comunidade de 300 casas em uma única
moradora
vi inclusive meu corpo como meio de
pesquisa para tudo isso acontecer e tem
algumas histórias que eu gostaria de
dividir com você como é o caso da dona
isabel de santana do araçuaí no vale do
jequitinhonha
a dona isabel na década de 60 recém
viúva e com quatro filhos pra criar a
fazia panelas de barro na tentativa de
suprir a fome enquanto isso é uma
constante ela vazia é panela de barro e
eu sábado chegava a caminhar 20
quilômetros para poder vender essas
peças na beira da estrada
foi um belo dia que ela entendeu que ela
continuasse fazendo aquilo que ela
sempre fez nada mudar então resolveu
inventar uma cabeça feminina para tampa
de uma das brigas corta a cena em 2004
ela ganha o primeiro lugar de um prêmio
da unesco de artesanato da américa
latina e suas peças cada vez mais
disputadas entre os colecionadores e
museus
dona isabel enquanto viva ensinou a
família e todos os vizinhos a trabalhar
com barro tanto é que hoje em dia grande
parte da economia de santana do araçuaí
vem por conta da artesanato de barro e
ela entendeu que enquanto ela dividiu
conhecimento ao invés dele se esgotar
eles só se multiplicaria são casos como
os que me fazem ser extremamente
apaixonado pelo brasil e por essas
pessoas que aqui moram
é o caso por exemplo do da costa daniel
rodrigues da costa
lá de cabaceiras aqui na maravilhosa
paraíba
o dodô desde pequeno tem os ouvidos
avaliadas para a música mas não tinha
condições de aprender o que ele fazia
pedia carona para chegar até a cidade
onde lá ele conseguia sinal de internet
grátis para carregar vídeos no youtube e
voltava para casa na tentativa de
reproduzir esses vídeos mas às vezes me
perguntam é como é que ele fazia isso
o dodô já que não podia é um dos
instrumentos resolveu inventar los e foi
assim que lançou os a materiais que
encontrava na redondeza e foi assim que
surgiu e se chocaria de crânio de
cachorro com sementes e unhas de bode
assim como também um reco-reco de
queixada de jumento apitos de barro e
pôr assim vai a música fica ótimo
certeza dodô atualmente se apresenta com
amigos nos festejos de cabeceira região
ele me disse eu queria muito
fui lá e dei um jeito sem saber que no
fim das contas nos ensina uma lição e
tanto também o caso do senhor jackson
que mora na beira do são francisco na
unidade com pouquíssimos recursos são
jackson ele fazia peças que achava que
valiam 200 reais o trabalho de três
semanas
as pessoas que por ali passavam
galeristas colecionadores chegaram a
oferecer 70 reais
minha gente 70 reais pelo trabalho de
três semanas diz contém ainda o valor da
matéria-prima
as pessoas ainda diziam faz mais barato
pra mim porque eu te ajudando todos
levando seu nome adiante
foi aí que eu resolveu encomendar a
algumas peças e já só que me pediu um x
e mesmo sem poder resolver pagar 4 x 1
ele olhou pra mim falou mas como assim
que tamanho vai ser essa peça polícia já
são exatamente do mesmo tamanho talvez
eu esteja só pagando o que é um
pouquinho mais justo
são essas histórias de pessoas que são
maravilhosas que acabam sendo
escanteados pelos autoridades pelo
governo sabe por quem mais por nós
mesmos como é que a gente valoriza a
cultura popular porque às vezes paga um
vaso 100 reais uma máquina produziu um
vaso de metal não é caro mas quando uma
pessoa que faz um vaso de barro e cobra
trinta reais que carrega uma tradição
secular vezes é caro demais
só que não é hora da gente revê como a
gente consome cultura popular
no fim das contas eu me tornei uma ponte
entre os artistas e quem é que quisesse
ouvir suas histórias
e foi assim contando essas histórias que
eu recebi um feedback unânime das
pessoas que seguiam novos para nós é um
respiro no meio de tanta tragédia que a
gente é bombardeado todos os dias eu não
eu não acredito e não acho que a minha
história teria sido a igual se não
tivesse tido esse contato com os
artistas
ah eu muito com eles aprendi lições que
eu vou levar para a vida toda
foi assim que o eu só consigo me lembrar
de caetano veloso gente é para brilhar
não para morrer de fome
esses artistas desperta em mim
sentimentos que a gente ainda não deu
nome e eu confesso que tem dias que
ainda bem que ela está junto comigo quem
diz que não quer ser nem mesmo o que eu
acho e o que eu acredito muito que
talvez eu tenha feito alguma coisa pela
vida desses artistas populares mas só eu
sei da mudança que eles fizeram na minha
esse deslocamento físico foi imenso mas
muito maior deslocamento de eixo que eu
passei
e aí eu só consigo me lembrar do
camarada guimarães rosa e eu como é que
eu posso explicar para o senhor o poder
de amor que eu criei minha vida que o
diga
não posso nem preciso dizer que não
carrega nenhuma gota de arrependimento
de ter feito essas mudanças que eu fiz
na minha vida arte popular é usada é
referente a ela é rústica é complicado
era inteligente e é uma grande
celebração de quem nós somos e eu divido
com vocês o meu grande aprendizado
nenhum sonho vem com garantias
ele só precisa ser maior que qualquer
medo ou insegurança
antes da gente terminar tão pessoal que
tem um recadinho pra vocês
obrigado obrigado obrigado obrigado
obrigado obrigado muito obrigado ler
[Música]
obrigado muito obrigado
[Aplausos]